madame monsieur bonsoir premier grand
titre de ce journal en ossétie la prise
d'otage de plusieurs centaines d'enfants
et d'adultes n'est pas terminée à
l'heure qu'il est les informations se
succèdent
elles sont parcellaires d'abord
concernant le nombre de victimes qui a
évolué toujours à la hausse
il y aurait plus de 150 morts 646 blessé
par ailleurs beaucoup de confusion
autour de l'école où une explosion a été
entendue en fin de soirée il y aurait
peut-être encore des otages à
l'intérieur nous y reviendrons mais
d'abord l'assaut des forces russes en
fin de matinée dans un certain désordre
contrainte d'intervenir réaffirme le
kremlin jean marc loos 11h ce matin et
deux explosions toujours inexpliquée le
toit du gymnase de l'école ou suffoquer
des centaines d'otages prend feu et
c'est fou c'est le début de scènes de
chaos qui vont durer plusieurs heures
avec d'abord la fuite sous les balles et
l'évacuation des premiers otages depuis
cinquante trois heures d'un commando
réclamant le départ des troupes russes
de la tchétchénie voisine
regardez le premier réflexe de ces
otages parfois à moitié nue et de se
jeter sur des bouteilles d'eau à l'abri
improbable de tanks russes postés aux
alentours
aso délibéré ou dérapages sanglants
difficile à dire ce qui est sûr c'est
que négociations ou pas ce sont
désormais les armes qui vont parler et
déjà des forces spéciales russes
s'infiltre par la brèche
si roanne ya ces mais nous étions en
train de négocier la restitution des
corps d'otages tué quand tout s'est
déclenché sur le chef de la sécurité
russes
on n'avait pas du tout décidé de lancer
d'assaut oui mais des enfants sont
peut-être prisonniers du gymnase en feu
et c'est donc sous la mitraille que les
pompiers vont s'efforcer de maîtriser
l'incendié
alors que par dizaines les parents food
angoisse ont franchi les cordons de
sécurité à la faveur de la confusion
générale
et cette fois-ci de l'assaut avec du
gros calibre à nassau professionnelle
certes mais qui semble bien improvisé
militaires civils policiers et
brancardiers comme à la mêlée
et avec parfois des moments de sauve qui
peut comme pour celle de femmes rares
témoignages sur les combats à
l'intérieur de l'école ces quelques
corps difficilement identifiables en fin
d'après-midi des preneurs d'otages
continuez à tirailler des étages
supérieurs sans que l'on sache si pour
couvrir leur fuite ils retenaient encore
d'autres otages